hey friends and welcome back to deep
dive if you're new here my name is ali
and in each episode i chat to authors
creators entrepreneurs and other
inspiring people about how they got to
where they are and the strategies and
tools that can help us collectively on
our shared journey of living healthier
happier more productive lives this
episode is a little bit special because
we've actually reached the end of season
two of the podcast it's been pretty
inspiring it's been great it's been very
exciting speaking to all the guests that
we've had across the last few weeks on
the podcast and so this video is going
to be a roundup of six of my favorite
lessons that i have learned through the
season of the podcast we're going to be
talking about lessons in meaningful
living lessons in entrepreneurship
lessons in dating lessons in side
hustles lessons in time management and
lessons in goal setting before we go
there just a few announcements firstly
the podcast is not going anywhere we are
returning for season three and in the
meantime in between season two and
season three starting we're going to be
having some bonus episodes and some q
a's with me so if you haven't subscribed
yet this is a good chance to do so
whether you're watching this on youtube
or listening on any podcast platform
secondly we are doing an end of season
survey so in the show notes and in the
video description you'll find linked a
survey we'd love to get your thoughts on
the podcast how we can make it better
what you like about it what you don't
like about it all that stuff because we
want to continue kind of showing up each
week and doing cool interviews and
conversations with people and trying to
provide as much value as we can for you
guys and thirdly we are actually in the
process of building a community around
my youtube channel around the stuff
around you know the people that watch
and listen to my stuff who are on this
shared journey of living healthier
happier productive lives and so we've
actually started a discord channel uh a
discord community discord server
whatever the terminology is that the
kids use these days it is called the
friend zone and it's completely free to
join uh there'll be a link in the show
notes or in the video description and
you can join the friend zone we've got
several thousand people there already
it's super nice and wholesome we've got
a channel for book discussions podcast
discussions people sharing tips about
how to code we've got like these
co-working study sessions it's really
cool very vibrant wholesome community
completely free of charge to join so you
can click the link in the video
description or in the show notes to join
that if you would like so those were the
announcements thank you very much for
listening to this season of the podcast
if you've been a listener for any length
of time and now let's roll some of my
favorite lessons favorite moments from
this season of the podcast let's go for
it towards the end of the book you've
got a whole section called um
on a meaningful life people have been
trying to answer this question for like
millennia so what what's the kind of
psychology recent scientific take on
what how how do we live a meaningful
life sure so a lot of the stuff from
that section is taken from i really like
using
um acceptance and commitment therapy act
um which has a whole
sort of part of that therapy is around
understanding your own values and what
gives you meaning and purpose in life
um
and
yeah so i've devoted a whole section to
it because i think it's so so important
and i also think it's important to
not just do it once but to keep doing
sort of little values check-ins where
you you just step back get a bit of a
bird's-eye view on what's going on in
your life at this point what matters
most to you at this point because it
changes right you know what was
important to you at 21 might not be the
same things that are important to you at
31. so your values change as you go
along but
the way um that we set it out in therapy
is is that
a value is like
a path
that you follow your whole life there is
no end to it but you just you value that
part so you want to stay close to it as
much as you can so a goal is something
you
once you've done it you you've done it
it's finished so your
your goal might be to do a marathon but
your value might be to stay fit and
healthy
and so the marathon becomes one of many
possible goals along the way but your
value is to
to continue to be fit and healthy along
the way
so that's the path yeah it's fitting
help you know fitness and health yeah um
and then there can be lots of her lots
of hurdles and lots of goals along the
way um
but at times life steers you away from
those so you know you might life happens
and maybe your job is very intense or
you have children or whatever it is and
it might stay away from that path and so
that's why i think it's so important to
do these regular sort of values
check-ins where you go
oh i'm not feeling quite right and
actually lots of people come to therapy
with that sort of sense of i'm not
really sure what the problem is i just
i'm feeling a bit lost or a bit you know
life feels a bit meaningless at the
moment and often that's because people
have lost touch with what's most
important to them or life has steered
them away from things that matter to
them
and so just getting clarity on what does
matter to me what is the most important
thing or things in my life at the moment
and what kind of person do i want to be
in those areas of my life
which then allows you to
set goals
based on
the life that you want to have or the
person that you want to be
how do you go about figuring out your
values
so there are lots of kind of little
exercises you do you can do
sometimes you can literally just grab a
piece of paper
um separate into little boxes you might
have boxes for
family life or
lifelong learning or
health or creativity so you can kind of
fill those boxes with different aspects
of your life and then in each box kind
of ask yourself
what kind of person do i want to be in
this area of my life so
maybe it's family relationships
what kind of son do i want to be to my
mum what kind of my dad and you know
what what kind of relationship do i want
to have
what do i want to represent to those
people
how would that show up in terms of
behavior and action you know daily
behavior um and you just kind of fill it
with with words or bullet points and
that gives you this this
picture of what life would be like if
you were living in line with all of
those values and sometimes they pull on
each other so sometimes they conflict
you know you might have this um real
idea of being a
um
you know successful entrepreneur but
actually that sucks all of your time and
you also want to be a family guy and you
want to spend time with your kids or you
know and so often there's this idea you
know this sort of this balancing act
where okay life has pulled me in one
direction and i want to pull it back
this way so it's not about
setting goals and doing them perfectly
it's about always just tipping the
balance um you know i haven't been
working out for a while because i've
been so focused on work so i know i'm
just going to come back in this
direction a little bit more and and
balance things out um so it's really
just getting clarity
but it's also not not focusing on um
what happens to you so it's not saying
this is what i want in my life because
then things can happen and then you
think i failed it hasn't worked out it's
really not it's really not about what
happens to you it's about
how you want to be
in the face of all the stuff that life
throws at us how do i want to respond
when hard stuff happens how do i want to
respond when i'm in a good place um and
stuff like that yeah as you were saying
this was like damn these are some really
good questions i should i should sit
down and answer something
um so is that like so
in in one of the early drafts of my book
proposal uh the first chapter was going
to be about like values and like meaning
and stuff
and after doing a bunch of stuff and
like reading an act textbook and things
i realized okay let me
leave this aside for now maybe this is
book three or four or five ten years
down the line when
20 or 30 years down the line when i have
more experience let's stick to the thing
that i actually can feasibly talk about
which is like productivity and fun and
stuff
um and so i came across a bunch of these
sort of value finding value funding
exercises uh so i've kind of figured out
what some of my values are i think
but
knowing that
and then actually
using it to change a decision that i
would have made otherwise
i haven't really done much of that like
how
let's say someone does these journaling
prompts and figures out okay i want to
be the sort of
son that does xyz i want to be the sort
of parent that does xyz
how do you how do you translate that
into physical like actual action yeah
that's where you know the therapy stuff
can be really helpful because it's a a
protected time in the week where you are
going to reflect on
those values and the things that you
want to work on
so they're not necessarily a big problem
but it's a direction you want to steer
to and so it becomes this place where
you're accountable to that and you go
and reflect on um in hindsight and
that's where it all begins is looking
back on things so you think okay here's
my map of you know all these different
values i have and things that are
important to me how how am i living in
line with them and you know how have i
been living in line with them in the
last two weeks
or have i you know and and
when when you look back and you think
gosh i really haven't
what what would i need to do to steer
back towards that value or to steer back
towards that path
um and then it creates a mini goal for
the week ahead you know and that's
really how therapy works is you know you
go and you have this sense of
accountability for yourself
there are things you want to work on and
you see how you've been getting on and
you tweak things a bit and you set a new
goal for the next week and then and then
you reflect on that again next week so i
think translating kind of ideas and
values into action
is really about
reflection and planning so you you learn
in hindsight you look back actually yeah
if i'm really really honest with myself
in the last couple of weeks have i been
living in line with that value yeah
whatever it was enthusiasm for example
and then
you know if if the answer is not really
you create a set of
you know specific actions that i will do
this week
to to move closer to that and then the
next week you reflect on well how was
that did it move me closer does that
feel enough do i need to do more do i
need to step back and those sorts of
things so it's just a always balancing
and tweaking and um
never ever doing it perfectly because
that's really not the aim
yeah i really like that model of like
it's like you're steering towards this
path that you've kind of decided that
this is the thing i care about for now
yeah um do values change much as we grow
older oh hugely i think yeah um
i mean
for me i i you know when i was i don't
know 19 or 20 i never even envisioned
myself as as being a parent i was really
focused on my studies and learning and
traveling and doing all those things um
but now that's without a doubt the most
important thing in my life so you know
that it's only a decade it's only you
know um
uh
you know it's it's not a long time but
but when life throws things at you and
life changes then you you know what what
matters to you changes as well and
that's okay you know you don't have to
be the same person yeah you learn and
grow and you would adapt to that i think
nice so
coming back to the overall question of
like
meaningful life it sounds like figuring
out your values is like a pretty
reasonable first step on the path of
like hey i know i mean we all basically
know that we want to live a meaningful
life but i think
very few of us actually
keep that in mind yeah when because it's
just it's it's kind of a bit a bit weird
like it's a bit out there to think ah
what's the meaning of life okay well let
me do some exercises and actually figure
this out rather than just dismissing it
as oh no one can ever figure that out
kind of thing yeah and i think we often
look outwards as well don't we we look
to
you know
we're bombarded with media that tell us
what
life should be about and what our
purpose should be
and
um
it's quite empowering when you give
yourself permission to
generate your own meaning and say well
actually you know
it is up to you what matters to you and
then you can structure life around that
life's still really really hard and
there are still responsibilities but how
you approach those responsibilities it's
really your choice um
and and that can be quite sort of
refreshing i think i think you don't
have to be gaining everybody's approval
you have to be looking at well
what would life be like if i approved of
myself if i approved of myself oh i
didn't like if i were kind of following
the path that i decided as meaningful
yeah so if i'm looking for my own
approval what what would i be doing you
know it's a sort of yes we can get
approval from other people but also
what would make me really pleased with
myself because those are my values
rather than necessarily being other
people's can you really dissociate that
like
you know let's say i value
i'm i'm considering applying to harvard
for like an mba
and i keep on like second guessing this
because i'm like why am i doing this
like i value prestige i value status i
value these badges of like
stuff is that really like me or is that
kind of what society plus or minus my
family have kind of instilled in to me
that makes me feel as if it's coming
from within if that makes sense
what's the gut feeling what's do you
feel that it's
come from outside no i don't feel like
it's come from outside but i also didn't
come out of the womb thinking i want to
i want to get a degree from cambridge
so there is some level of like you know
it wasn't a genetic decision there is
some level of like socialization that
goes into this sort of stuff yeah and i
guess i wondered to what extent
the fact that
i know that probably a large chunk of my
identity is socialized in some to some
degree does that still make me
me or does it make me a product of my
the society have been brought up in and
then how do i like find my true meaning
if
well it's society that's told me that a
harvard and cambridge degree is like a
good thing does that make sense yeah
absolutely because we're all a product
of our upbringings and our cultures and
all those kind of things aren't we so
you know i don't think it's about sort
of finding this one truth i think it's
about creating the meaning and holding
on to things that you know
what a wonderful thing that would be to
do if that was what you would enjoy and
find inspiring and exactly so you know i
think you can that's the beauty of it is
um when
when you're in a position
that you can choose those things
then you can decide um yes it might be
that i've i've learned
you know some of these sort of
ideas around prestige of universities
and stuff
but actually i would really enjoy that
and it would give me a lot of meaning
and purpose it doesn't matter if if it
came from someone else if you agree with
it you know
whereas if you feel that's good
pressured and it's not something you
want to do but you feel like you're
doing it because
you know someone will disapprove of you
if you don't and that's slightly
different isn't it yeah but if it's
something you love
and you would get good memories from and
i think i think it's kind of like
like realistically the reason i go to
the gym is not for myself it's to look
more attractive
but i also agree that it's a good thing
to do and therefore who cares what the
prime motivation is it's a good thing to
do exactly you can kind of use all the
different aspects of pressure and to
your own advantage a lot of thoughts
that are sparked through through that
have you come across uh the e-myth oh
yeah oh big that was that was a super
early read for me so i to go back to
starting a business i was a classic uh i
was a coffee obsessive i was like well i
understand coffee i'm good at making
coffee i should open a coffee business
and uh very quickly it was like oh
then there's the business of business
and uh how rapidly can i get good at the
business of business to build sort of
the machine underlying that and and i
didn't have time to do anything other
than read
and read i did and so yeah michael
gerber's book i think was uh super super
informative very relevant to me and
further encouragement to to work on the
business or in it uh which becomes
slightly glib when you say it but it's
so
so important yeah i can't i can't you
know what i mean i can't emphasize
enough that the need to get out from the
the the daily of the manufacturing of a
business whatever it is that you make
and sell and do into a higher level
think uh or so a thought process
to understand the model the mechanics of
the it's a machine right you're tweaking
cogs and you're kind of making it work
just nice
that's hard and you need to get good at
that and that has nothing to do with
coffee yeah that's nothing to do with
coffee and everything to do with
understanding
everything from people through to sort
of marketing sales
economics finances reading a balance
sheet understanding the impacts of
decisions you make on your balance sheet
on your future and your cash flows all
of that sort of stuff
i really enjoyed it which is fortunate
uh lots of people are immediately turned
off and go to the safe space of the
thing that they know and care about and
and that's
you know not healthy for the business
long term yeah yeah i think that's an
insight that so many people have only
only once they have started a business
yeah yeah when you realize oh actually i
don't know like
i guess i guess
youtube is a different example because
you do actually make money from it but
like you know
just being good at making coffee does
not does not make me a good
owner of a or or manager or operator of
a of a coffee business
um
and so i first read the myth i think in
like 2019 or something and i had a
business at that point i've been going
for five years and i was like my god i
wish i'd read this book five years ago
because all of the mistakes under the
sun oh yeah and the first time i came
across that phrase that you know you
should be working on the business not in
it i was just like my mind was
completely blown and now it's just so it
feels so standard to me that i almost
can't remember a time where i didn't
know that that was a thing right and
even now when kind of coaching youtubers
and stuff this is the thing i try and
encourage more creators to think a
little bit more businessy because i
think creators are very easy at thinking
like oh it's about the craft it's about
the video i want to make sure it's about
how it makes me feel which is fine
but also i think if you have if you want
to turn it into a business there is a
level of let's actually approach this
from a slightly more businessy angle i
got very interested in the idea of
um
sustainable businesses
you know because i how do you build a
business that that uh exists
outside of the people that work within
it
um
and and this in coffee is a particular
challenge because
go back to this and i'll promise to make
sense of it you do loads of bristol
training as a coffee roaster and
supplier you train loads of people and
what you end up feeling is that you're
just pouring water into a bucket with a
hole in it because you train a bunch of
people they leave because they're just
there for a little bit and
the business itself doesn't retain the
knowledge
and you look at businesses that are
hundreds of years old how did they how
did they exceed the will or the ideas of
one person and become this thing where
they are almost a living entity
themselves and you get into the boring
answers of like systems and structure
and you build a business that is able to
retain knowledge independent of the
people that work within it and that
isn't a bad thing that doesn't strip
people of their value or utility that
makes their job easier more enjoyable
because they can still access that
information and knowledge but when they
leave
the half your business doesn't work out
yeah that for me became a very uh
interesting sort of thing to think about
of like how do you treat it like a
a a thing that can learn independently
right can you teach a business and we
got very interested in this with a bunch
of customers like okay we need to stop
just training your baristas we'll keep
doing that but we need to work with you
in a way of collecting and systemizing
the knowledge that we are delivering so
that it's yours
regardless of who's executing it and
that sounds dehumanizing but it but it i
don't think it is i think it's it's
about creating actually a much healthier
environment
for to work in where you don't feel like
you you can't leave because you'd break
the business that's a really and a lot
of people have felt that way of like i
can't leave when i want to i want to do
something else but i feel stuck here
because i know
too much of this company rests on me and
that's an awful thing to do to someone
it's not good retention that's a bad
it's a bad thing um
so yeah i i think not enough people talk
about that the idea of like
you know be it a founder or key people
or you know
the business itself has to retain
information knowledge it has to have a
purpose bound
into it to be sustainable long term yeah
yeah i think this is again one of the
one of those things that you only really
start to appreciate once you have a
business and before
uh when i was reading about businesses
system structure processes hr values
vision what the hell is all that
[ __ ] and then as soon as you start
like oh okay now now i see what's
happening now i see why i i like
it's you know with with my first
business it's bad that i'm i am the one
staying up until 12 at midnight making
sure that our book deliveries for our
course which is happening in manchester
tomorrow have actually arrived because
i'm the only one who knows how to deal
with the supplier that's probably bad
probably right this is figuring out all
these things like oh my god like what
started off as
me enjoying teaching courses for medical
applicants now turning into turning it
into a business is actually a lot of the
quote boring stuff which then at least
for me became the fun stuff when i
realized how much there was to learn and
how much of a kind of uh what the
learning curve was like and that every
new book i was reading i was just my
mind was blown like oh my god businesses
have been solving these problems
problems for decades after hundreds of
years there is a system behind this and
i can learn the system um yeah i think
that's the that's the off you know i
think for me though i read loads and
loads of loads of books but there was
still the kind of lag of
the conversion of information to
knowledge through the the application of
it you know i mean like it took me doing
it messing it up doing it again messing
it up to kind of get to the point where
okay now i truly understand the ideas
here and and how they work uh yeah yeah
it's like it's all it's all well and
good to read a book about hiring but
until you've done it and made mistakes a
bit yeah absolutely and you know like uh
you know i come from i suppose a family
of entrepreneurs so i was fortunate in
that i had
in my family people to be like hiring is
going to be the hardest bit uh
you know
all the advice they gave me i was like a
little bit blase about the time
it's going to be really hard study
business is really hard like really hard
got it great and then like a year and
you're like this is really hard why
didn't you tell me and they're like
what's wrong with you uh and then like
hiring is going to be
the hardest bit and it's about it stays
the hardest bit forever and you're like
nah how long could it be in the first
stop we had a really great first few
people yeah and i'm like this is fine
this is easy and you're like no no no no
you learn a bunch of awful lessons and
and um
you know it still remains the hardest
part and and
especially if you want to you know i i
think that
there are
businesses out there that still want to
find a human extract the value
on you go yeah you know i mean that's
not that's for us not that interesting
we're interested in development enjoying
where you work satisfaction all of that
kind of stuff you know it's the the
slightly trite line of like we want to
be the place where you do your best work
but i think that's very true for what we
certainly aspire to but that obviously
it doesn't make things harder it just
changes the challenge and changes the
sort of focus the great lesson from my
point of view is that we didn't start
with enough um because i worked too many
chapters yeah yeah so i fell for the the
classic
what's that can i swear here yeah oh
great um so the hero [ __ ] of
entrepreneurship of like i must grind
myself down
i'm a [ __ ] hero working super hard
i'm doing it right and it's such
[ __ ] and it's such a toxic aspect of
all work and i hate it but i definitely
worked 110 hour weeks for like months
ground myself down to the point of deep
misery and there is no quicker way
to hate a thing you love
that than to work like to work on it
like that right like i really love
coffee i definitely got to the point
where i was like i should quit coffee i
should just i i hate this i hate this i
hate my life i hate working in this i
should just do something else because i
worked in a stupid way and i burnt
myself out physically and emotionally
because people do that because the world
says good for you get the grind on you
know i mean what it's your thing it's
yours pull yourself into it you're like
no don't don't do that that's really bad
what you should do is start with enough
capital that you can hire people to work
with you pay them properly
and then work in a healthy manner do you
know what i mean like just have work and
home uh be separate that's helpful turn
off don't work at weekends or don't work
some days a week it's very satisfying
early doors to pour yourself into a
business it is rewarding it's enjoyable
but
you're just burning through yourself so
fast and so i regret not starting with
probably twice as much money hiring more
people out of the gate and going home at
five o'clock do you know what i mean
like just be done just turn it off turn
off the go home enjoy life you can build
this thing you don't have to sacrifice
yourself for this
the downside is you need more money to
start with so that's that's the
trade-off
we didn't have that money we didn't know
we needed it we had enough to buy the
physical things not enough to build the
systems hire the people and so we just
worked ourselves to the bone and it was
miserable and i regret it and it was a
mistake oh okay
on that point so
i feel like sort of
at least in the online
online discourse around starting
businesses circa 2013 to 2019
was the era of the hustle culture
movement saying that like you're
starting from nothing your 20s are for
hustling you gotta grind yourself to the
ground work on weekends work on evenings
to make that to start that thing
since pandemic i think has accelerated
this there's a lot more like
that kind of approach of actually
sustainability is important etc etc um
but what a lot of the kind of pro-hustle
people say is that look when
when you don't have that start-up
capital like and you're working your
crappy job and you need to start the
business there is not much you can do
other than kind of work between i don't
know 7 p.m and 2 a.m and also work on
weekends and all that kind of stuff and
i guess you're just hoping it's just a
season of time so that you can build
enough money build the business off the
ground because it will take blood
theoretically it takes blood sweat and
tears to get a business off the ground
from from moment one
um
and a lot of entrepreneurs that i've
spoken to who have done that kind of
were grinding themselves to the ground
say that yeah it wasn't ideal it wasn't
really a happy time but without that
period of crunch which for several years
potentially the business wouldn't have
gotten off the ground so i guess my
question to you is do you think that you
would have been able to do it in a more
nice sustainable way or do you think it
was necessary to put in the blood to to
get this get this off the ground i think
i think that the tricky bit is that if i
had had the understanding that i have
now
and a little bit more capital then yes
we could have built the same business
far more enjoyably i don't think it had
been a bigger business necessarily but
it would have been a more enjoyable
process to to do that we're going to
take a very quick break to introduce our
sponsor for this episode who is
brilliant i've been using brilliant for
the last few years and they're a
fantastic interactive platform with
online courses in maths science and
computer science my personal favorites
are the computer science courses i think
are absolutely fantastic and when i was
initially applying to med school i was
actually torn between applying to
medicine and applying to computer
science and i ended up going with
medicine in the end which i really don't
regret but there's a big part of me that
really wanted to continue learning the
stuff around computer science continuing
to understand how coding works and the
courses on brilliant have given me that
foundation in computer science which i
didn't have before the courses are
really fun engaging and interactive and
the way they teach you stuff is based on
very first principles thinking like
they'll teach you a concept and then
they'll take you through interactive
exercises to actually help solidify your
understanding of that concept and it's
pretty cool because they're always
updating the library with new courses
for example there's one they've just
released called everyday maths which is
kind of like a visual exploration of the
maths that we use in everyday life like
for example fractions and percentages
and putting them in a context that makes
it very understandable and certainly
very different to the kind of boring way
that i was taught maths when i was in
school the courses and lessons are
particularly good if you have a busy
life with lots of stuff going on because
they really teach you the stuff in
bite-sized chunks so you can always
return to a course at a later date if
you don't have time to do it in one
sitting if any of that stands up your
straight then do head over to
brilliant.org forward slash deep dive
and the first 200 people to hit that
link which is also going to be in the
video description and in the show notes
we'll get 20 off the annual premium
subscription so thank you so much to
brilliant for sponsoring this episode so
my whole thing is date like a scientist
so date like a scientist is have some
hypotheses test them
bring the data back to me and we will
try to understand what that means and so
maybe at the end of our first session we
said we think you're a maximizer we
think that you have unrealistic
expectations of partners and we think
that the next time that you go on a
second date and you don't want to go in
a third we're going to push you to go in
the third because it's in that third
that you will deepen the relationship
and get to know this person versus
rejecting them for something silly
if your issue was that you were a
hesitator and you weren't putting
yourself out there your next step would
be getting a dating app and
trying to go on more dates
and so what's the point of a dating app
profile
the point
is to
create a great first impression
and so your dating app profile is almost
like you walking into a bar and giving
off a particular vibe so if you're
wearing a game of thrones t-shirt people
are going to engage with you on that if
you're wearing a tutu or a basketball
jersey people are going to engage with
you in different ways and so how do you
want people to see you and then respond
to you and so i can get into the weeds
but
really your dating app profile should
tell a story it should have variety it
should say this is me when i'm with my
family and friends and this is what
dating me would look like this is a full
body shot of me so you can see what i
look like in the world here's a clear
picture of my face without filters or
sunglasses so you know what i look like
here's me doing an activity that i love
and i want you to ask me questions about
it so you're really painting a picture
you want to have variety you want to
have clear photos that show us who you
are we don't want to be playing
where's wally and wondering which one
you are in a different picture and
really you're putting yourself out there
so that somebody can see who you are
know what you look like and most
importantly
you're creating a hook that they can
grab onto and then engage you in a
conversation okay so dating ups um one
of my core beliefs is that everyone who
is single that i know should be on
dating apps and only about half of them
are and there's a few common objections
that i get when i try and talk people
into making accounts on dating apps um
can i just throw a few of them a few of
them at you and i would love to hear it
absolutely okay let's do um
dating apps are just for hookups what's
going on there
i work at hinge hinge is really about
getting people off of the app and on to
relationships i know that's sort of a
tagline but in the two years that i've
been there i've really found that to be
true we're obsessed with helping people
go out on great dates there are
different dating apps that serve
different purposes but if you're someone
who's really looking for a relationship
a so are a lot of people on certain apps
like hinge and b you should feel free to
be upfront from the beginning about what
you're looking for so we just ran this
fascinating experimented hinge where we
showed 12 000 different users
for profiles some of the profiles said
they were looking for something generic
you know kind compassionate adventurous
some of the profiles said
i am looking for a long-term
relationship what we found is that if
the person in the experiment was also
looking for a long-term relationship
they were much more likely
17 more likely to send the person who
was looking for a relationship a message
because they were like great you've
taken the guesswork out of this i want
something you want something i'll
message you
if the person looking at the profile did
not want a relationship they were 10
percent less likely to send that person
a message and that actually saves you
time on both ends you get more messages
from the kind of people you want to hear
from and fewer messages from the kind of
person you don't and so a lot of this is
just being bold being courageous being
up front from the beginning whether it's
on your profile or the first and second
date about what you in particular want
to get out of this experience nice love
it so objection number two is dating
apps focus too much on the superficials
and as a sub point to that it's mostly
guys that i speak to about this uh guys
are systematically um uh
shall we say
shafted in the dating market because
um you know there are so many more guys
on this app than there are girls and
i've tried it a couple of times and i
never get any matches and then i look at
one of my female friends and they're
getting freaking 100 matches a day like
ugh as a guy dating apps are not for me
there are issues where dating apps can
reduce you to this two-dimensional image
that people are evaluating and without a
lot of context they might immediately go
for looks
one thing that hinge just released is
these voice prompts and this is a chance
for people to be silly they could do an
impression of their favorite cartoon
character they could play you a silly
song that they've been writing they
could
you know do a celebrity impression
whatever that is and it's a chance to
bring more authenticity to the profile
and so i'd say in general i think the
future of what we're going to be seeing
with dating apps is wanting more
information whether it's more video more
voice more interactivity so it's not
just like hey here's a piece of paper
with bio data on it that your mom showed
you and you have to say yes or no i want
to go on a date with this person but
really it will feel more like oh i've
seen you on social media i get a sense
for how you move through the world i get
a sense for what you look like what your
voice sounds like i have an immediate
response to who you are and so i would
say for those people what can need you
on their end to bring their more full
self to the profile and then also in
their own behavior on the app how can
they try to give more people a chance
because if we focus too much on height
or age we're actually filtering out a
lot of people who could make great
potential partners okay so we've got the
profile where we've we've matched with a
few people we've got hinge premium
because why not
such a time saver um this is another
thing this is another hill that i died
with a bunch of my friends like why
would you not like you're making decent
money you work at mckinsey why would you
not pay 17 quid every six months
it just begs but anyway i think about
that all the time in terms of like how
much would you pay to find the love of
your life and for a lot of people you
know depending on their pay scale it's a
lot of money so why aren't you putting
money behind that why aren't you
you know investing in some good date
outfits whether it's paying for a dating
app or even i have a friend who runs an
incentive program where if you
it's actually through her dad if you set
her up on five dates either five dates
with one person or five dates with
different people some combination he
will send you this gift basket from
nuts.com
which i just think is so funny and
random but why it works is
psychologically it makes you feel like
okay this person's really serious about
dating
she's willing to go out with whoever you
set her up with and there's an incentive
and so it makes me put in the extra
effort to set her up and so if anyone's
listening and feels motivated put your
money where your mouth is and offer an
incentive to your friends to set you up
it might just make the difference
between them saying yes and i'm actually
doing it
yeah so on that note there was a blogger
that i that i follow um his name is
tynan uh he was he was actually featured
in the game back in the day uh the book
oh wow um he was he was one of the
people in the house but he ended up kind
of growing out of that becoming like a
sort of personal development blogger
type guy and
building businesses and things and i i
interviewed him on this on one of these
like streams about two years ago uh he
had a thing that when he turned 30 he
posted to his mailing list saying look
i'm serious about getting to know
someone if you introduce me to the
person i end up in a long-term
relationship i will i will a long-term
relationship with i will help you tick
off any item on your bucket list and he
got a bunch of like inbound that way and
when i when i heard about that that
really resonated with me because it
really was a case of put your money
where your mouth is and take this
seriously but i mentioned it to some
people and they were like that's a bit
weird it's dating shouldn't be so
systematic and stuff like
what what the hell is wrong with you um
i don't know if you could if you got
that like the whole like scientific
approach to dating and stuff do you get
that pushback that like oh it's supposed
to be more natural than that
first of all i have chills from that
story because it's so clever like i love
that it was at the milestone of turning
30. i love those to his email list i
also think tick something off your
bucket list is just such an amazing
prompt and probably better than money
because it like helps you release it and
say like what's my bucket list and
what's holding me back and maybe even if
you don't win that contest or whatever
you still might make progress on it but
for the general question yes people ask
me all the time why are you trying to
apply research to something that's
organic and how can you bottle up love
so my response to them it's actually the
first paragraph of my book is that yes
love is natural and we're born knowing
how to love
but dating isn't
dating in the modern sense was invented
at the end of um around 1890 so this is
a relatively new concept in terms of the
span of human history and then dating on
apps is around a decade old with um
swiping and all that being extremely new
and so part of it is just
having humility around the fact that a
lot of us are just making this up as we
go along this is not something that we
know how to do second of all in history
people would help you right there was
the matchmaker or maybe your father
would
have you marry the person next door so
that your parcels of land connected or
he would trade your hand in marriage for
10 camels there was all these other
people involved it's actually a really
new concept that you on your own define
all of these characteristics of your
life including who you marry and so
people need help second of all there is
academic research on this we talked
about this there's research on
attraction research on do opposites
attract research on what makes for a
long-term compatible relationship
why wouldn't you look at that if you
were gonna make a nutrition plan or a
financial plan you would look at the
research why is love something that has
to defy logic and defy science and so
i'd say this is something that you care
about and you want to find someone great
and not get divorced why wouldn't you
invest in knowing the information out
there it can only empower you and you
can take the parts of it that are useful
and you can ignore the other parts one
of the things that you talk about is the
sort of
actively reflecting on a date when you
get back from it
um and i wanted to ask like to what
extent like what are the sorts of
questions that we should be asking when
we get back from dates and to what
extent is like
a sort of checklist approach to this a
good idea because we talk about things
like growth mindset and emotional
maturity and ability to communicate is
that the sort of thing like similar to
how like if you're hiring someone for a
job you want to have like a scorecard
and you want to be able to evaluate each
candidate against the scorecard is this
the sort of person who would be able to
do x to what extent is that like a
decent approach when it comes to dating
and reflecting on dates afterwards
in general i think that
having a checklist is not helpful
because often what's on that checklist
is the wrong stuff it's height
income perceived success
do we have the same hobbies i think a
lot of times that checklist is based on
what we think matters in long-term
relationships which the research shows
us doesn't matter in long-term
relationships so as a concept i would
say throw out your checklist be willing
to date someone who's not your type it
is very possible that the person you end
up with the person who makes it you
happiest long-term is not the person you
thought you would be with that being
said in my book i offer this exercise
called the post date eight
the post date eight is based on research
on gratitude journals so there's amazing
research from many people including sean
acor of harvard that says if at the end
of the day you have to write down three
things that you're grateful for your
brain will actually be looking for them
throughout the day so if you're running
to make the bus and you make it maybe
five minutes later you forget about it
but if you know that at that night you
have to write it down then you're going
to notice it more so what we do at the
end impacts what we look for throughout
so the post date eight is the same idea
i've taken what i believe and what the
research shows matters for evaluating a
date i've turned it into these list of
eight questions things like how did i
feel in my body around this person do i
feel curious about this person what side
of me did this person bring out and then
throughout the date
you aren't looking at their height and
their job you're paying attention to
those things and at the end of the date
you ask yourself the post date eight to
decide do i want to see this person
again and so it is a version of a
checklist but it's a checklist designed
to help you focus on what matters not
what doesn't nice and i wonder if you
can give some examples of like what are
some of the questions in the post date
eight
sure so
from all the research that i've done and
even the coaching i've done since my
book has come out this one of what side
of me did this person bring out is huge
because it helps you understand great on
paper brings out a bad side of me i
don't want to see them again that's a
really helpful insight another one is
this idea of do they energize me or
de-energize me so
there's an activity called a penthouse
in a basement person you think in your
life not even in a romantic setting who
is my penthouse person who when i'm with
them do they bring my energy up do i
feel creative do i feel inspired so for
you who's your penthouse person he's my
penthouse person uh i can think of a few
university friends i think my brother is
one of my penthouse people which is why
we kind of decided to start a podcast
together um my current housemate is a
penthouse person
definitely i love that yes so you have
this penthouse person that's another
helpful benchmark and you have a
basement person somebody who makes you
feel depressed down de-energized and so
just asking this question did i feel
more energized or less energized after
the date helps you understand where that
person falls and helps you get closer to
finding a penthouse person because of
course the person you end up with in a
romantic relationship you want them to
bring out that inspired capable creative
part of you
and so it's really helping you
understand what stuff matters what stuff
to pay attention to and it ignores
things like
did i think they have an impressive job
and do we have enough
hobbies and comments stuff that people
think matters but really doesn't i was
trying to work out what age you started
various companies and it was like
surprisingly later in life than people
would initially think people think
founders like you know 17 to 19 year
olds mark zuckerberg the stripe guys
yeah um but you were like 30 something
when you started i would have been 36 37
and um yeah i yeah most of these sort of
podcasts can focus around the sort of
very younger guys and yeah you think
about the zuckerberg because the world's
incredibly young well i think he's done
ben francis reasoning incredibly young
so i think that it's um
yeah i think it's interesting that most
people probably think when they get 36
day seven they're sort of stuck in what
they're doing yeah they can't retrain
they can't relearn
but yeah i did i just sort of had a had
a need had a personal reason why i
needed to start working from home
and i had to suss that out and i did a
lot of stuff you sort of do is listen to
a lot of podcasts tons of podcasts read
a lot online
and try and work out and sort of bodge
your way through to start off with so it
took me about a year before i got the
confidence to jack my job in but worked
evenings and weekends
yeah it must be 36.37 yeah so when you
so um i i speak to a lot of people in
their like sometimes even late teens but
like early to mid 20s who say oh i don't
know what i want to do i haven't figured
it out it seems like all these other
people are sort of like going ahead of
me yeah um
what was your kind of experiences during
school and sort of like late teens early
20s um and how did how did we go from
that to
and then
starting a business like
so i left score at 16
um pretty poor gcses um what did i get
three c's maybe these e's got two e's
for english i do remember that i can't
spell i'm not really gonna read it
either really it's got two years for
english left at 16
worked at a shop for a year then worked
digging holes in the road for two years
as manual labor
um
then i think my girlfriend at time was
about 90 she goes what are you doing
digging holes in the road you're too
smart to do that so i wasn't
academically smart i saw quite smart at
certain stuff
so i went back to college
two years
and i thought i'd come out then get a
job came out of college with two
i think it was a b tech i had
couldn't get a job off the back of that
so i had nothing else to do really apart
from went to uniform and now i'm
committed i've given up work i might as
well keep going so then i got a
placement at bournemouth university did
a degree in marketing came out of that i
thought i'd get a job straight away no
problem didn't i scam work i remember i
worked night shifts in the petrol
station for six months
and um
and then luckily i think it was my
stepmom she worked with somebody whose
husband worked somewhere and luckily i
got a job in marketing finally after all
that so i'd had a degree mark had a 2-1
but couldn't get a job luckily i got one
i worked in the marketing team
from about i think that must be 1999
something like that worked in marketing
for mostly retailers so that was when
you were like 25 fish yeah yeah maybe a
little bit older 25 26 something like
that and um
and then
then i started uh internet sort of came
along yeah so this was still quite early
because i think when i was at uni i
think i was finishing union 96
and the internet like really not really
about you know i think i think at
university you could use some of the
computers there you could access the
internet but nobody really had a home
computer of internet 96
and um
and then when i first got my job i was
just doing normal sort of marketing as a
marketing assistant and then the
internet came along so somebody said can
you have a look at this internet thing
should we have an internet business i
was working for mfi which is a furniture
retailer at the time and i sort of said
to them yeah it looks like you should
um being q which was a bigger retailer
at the time had a what they called a
brochure where site hadn't you couldn't
buy no e-commerce i said well we could
we could beat them we could overtake
them if you give me some money so i sort
of persuaded the the team or the board
to give us
67 000 pounds and start the first
website
got that built by an agency
got that going and then of course i was
almost a you know within one year i was
almost a gray beard in terms of internet
experience because nobody had it so then
i moved on work for some other retailers
and then fast forward to
um
yeah 2000 and
2008 i think it was
um
i needed to work from home
because of a personal reason
and um
i thought [ __ ] what i'm going to do
because i lived in the house we were out
and sort out the countryside i was
working in london and going an hour and
a half each way so it was three hours of
driving a day
so i wanted to work from home no
marketing jobs of any sort of merit in
in aylesbury area so i needed to create
my own business
and uh so i started looking around and
luckily at the time we were using some
affiliates and affiliates are people
basically who sit at home and create
websites
and make money from sitting in their pjs
i suppose at home yeah this is something
i can do maybe these guys i met i met
them i went to an affiliate event and uh
these guys i thought they make it i knew
how much something someone making like
10 20 000 pounds a month if you hold
your [ __ ] there's loads of money
and um
and i met them i thought they were going
to be i don't know i'm not saying their
flight is going to be geniuses but when
i met them i thought
they're bright but they're not like
rocket scientists i thought if they can
do it why can't i do it so that was
basically me then thought right i'm
going to learn how to do this by myself
by listening to podcasts
by practicing starting websites learning
learning learning yeah so i used to get
home from work at say six o'clock
on a work day
um
have my uh meal
with my my wife at a time and then go on
the computer at seven o'clock i
basically had my computer there set up
in the lounge so i could sit in a lounge
watch tv i had a little mirror set up i
could use to watch the tv while i was uh
working yeah and worked to say 11
o'clock do this at the weekends as well
did that nearly sort of full time for a
year until i got staged where i started
making about a thousand pounds maybe
fifteen hundred two thousand pounds a
month
and started thinking i know how to do
this if i had more time i could double
the amount of work i would double the
amount of money i could earn
and so i remember saying to my wife at
the time said right i'm going to have a
crack at this
i'm going to jack my job in
i'm going to give myself six months if i
can't get the same amount of money i get
my salary within six months i'll go back
and get that job again or get a similar
type of job and i think at that time i
had a good enough experience that i felt
confident i could go back and get a job
so it felt like pretty low risk
and um i thought as long as i could earn
the same salary
and i'm working from home it's a win-win
i've got three hours a day i'm not
traveling so that was the goal within
three months i was earning more than my
salary and then he just kept on going
after that yeah i think that's uh when i
think when when when people quit a job
um
i feel like they often have this idea
that oh you know i'm working a 30k job
therefore quitting the job is a 30k risk
but it's actually not because like next
week you could probably get a 28k job if
you really wanted to and so really it's
not a 30k risk it's a 2k risk between
the job that you currently have and the
job that you could pretty easily get if
you need it to and even if you take a
little bit of a pay card maybe you can't
get a 35k job immediately but at least a
25 28k job is is very reasonable in that
context um and i don't know anyone who's
kind of done done that and regretted the
decision because you're sort of like
going all in on yourself and giving
yourself that be like yeah i'm i've i've
i've got to make this work and if i
don't then it's not the end it's not the
end of the world i'll just get another
job if you talk about it and sort of
practice at it forever you're never
going to do it somehow you do have to
make that hard decision to do it yeah
but i would never i've never would have
done it before i'd been yet practicing
and learning for a year so even as a
weekend was vitally important i think if
you do that and really do it and start
earning money you build confidence the
more you do something the more
confidence you get so i was pretty
confident the end of that year
i said if i double the amount of time i
can work on this or triple the amount of
times i probably could have tripled the
amount of time i know i will do this
yeah so i was pretty confident but yeah
i put enough money to one side to pay
the mortgage pay all the bills for six
months which is not a lot if you just
strip everything out of your life apart
from the mortgage and the food bills you
don't need that much so it wasn't a ton
of cash but i put enough money in the
bank that had that saved that up over
that previous year for the money i had
to earn from it put that to one side
that was enough
um but yeah it was three months and i
was earning more yeah so one
one thing i i often hear from people is
this idea of
you know i want to do this side hustle
therefore i'm going to quit my job and
i'm going to make it happen i would be
like hang on hang on like don't don't
quit your job until you've at least done
it for a little while yeah in in the
weekends and yeah weekends evenings um
but i guess these days it's it's sort of
become a bit unfashionable to talk about
doing the stuff on the weekends and
evenings and things and everyone's like
oh but like sustainability and like you
know work-life balance and mental health
and all that kind of stuff rightly so
um but i think there is still that
balance between like the people who sort
of succeed are the ones who do add in
that extra level of hustle extra level
of grind if you want to use those words
yeah i i think that you've all got to
you know to make something work there's
gonna have to be a period of time when
you have to go outside of your comfort
zone you're gonna have to work harder
than you you probably
healthfully should over a long period of
time but you're not doing that forever
so
um that was one year but i
worked crazy crazy amount of hours i'm
doing a full-time job with a three-hour
drive backwards and forwards to hide me
one hour and a half each way yeah and
then working in the evening so there was
crazy hours for a year big deal i you
know i felt like there was such an end
goal at the end of it it was worth it
yeah and then when i started working at
high when i checked the job i wasn't
doing all these evenings and weekends so
there's only one year
that was pretty easy in fact i end up
started working at two to finish at two
or three o'clock when somebody started
rolling in i was even finishing early to
make up for that previous year then i
suppose when i started sure that that
that that was tough when that kicked off
there was two to three years of that
when it that was crazy crazy hours but
now i'm 50 years old i've given you
example basically four years in total
out of 50 well i've worked crazy hours
that feels doable in my house it feels
doable um
so when you were when you were making
this money or attempting to make this
money from the affiliate stuff well why
you still had the job and you were
commuting three hours yeah what was it
that kept you going in those those
weekends and evenings while you're
knackered from a day of work and driving
back and back and forth and you get on
the computer you're like
what what's what's going through your
mind well this was that dream of not
being able to do that three hours we
never sit in that car yeah because this
was the day before um in the days before
podcast basically live into radio radio
with adversity and driving backwards and
falls into london it's pretty you know
so destroying and you think there's this
dream have i met these guys i remember
going to this event these guys were
there no brighter than me
i think one of them had an aston martin
one might have had a ferrari working
from home and you think there's that's a
dream so you just think if i just
knuckled down for that one year it keeps
you going to do that and i thought and
also you know there's progress in that
year as well so during that year you
will see times when nothing's happened
and then she might have a little win a
little wind little win so you get like
little wins all the way through and yeah
clearly if i don't no money through that
whole time it literally just knuckled
down for a whole year nothing had
happened that probably would have been
tougher than i thought yeah but because
those wins and money's coming in at
different times
it brings it back to the yeah if i keep
going this i keep going i keep going
i'll get there eventually yeah yeah i
think in my life uh it would have been
around the same time like 2008 to
2010-ish
um i had like two distinct moments uh
one was when i first started doing
freelance web design and made like a few
dollars through a paypal account where i
lied about my age because i was like 14.
uh i
made like ten dollars through like
editing some like mysql code from some
of the website i was like bloody hell i
can make money on the internet and the
second one was actually through
affiliates right um i i made this like
site that would get people to sign up
for love film affiliates yeah which is
like the pre-blockbuster pre-netflix era
and a friend of mine used his own
family's credit cards to sign up for
four free trials and i remember getting
a check in the mail for 50 quid which
was one of those like um electronic
checks where it's like tens of millions
zero millions zero tens of thousands
zero is like tens five i was like bloody
hell i made 50 quid and i
you know didn't have to work for it
directly yeah and it was just having
those two experiences of a making money
through selling my web design services
and then making money through building
this affiliate site that just gave me
such confidence that this is a thing you
can make money on the internet i can i
can make money through a business and i
think it was that sort of formative
experiences that meant when i was at uni
and started my first business that
actually worked i had the conviction and
the knowledge and the experience and
having failed it but a bunch of things
before to be able to make that work yeah
and i guess it kind of sounds similar so
similar experience to what you had yeah
i think that i'm i've certainly i've
said it before i don't think i'm
particularly i don't think i'm
particularly brilliant at anything i'm
very good at marketing now so i've done
it for such a long period of time i
think naturally at school i wasn't
particularly brilliant anything the
beauty of like say working on uh
e-commerce or creating content or doing
whatever is if you put enough hours in
you can sometimes beat somebody with
more talent than you whereas like i
don't know football you got a football
pitch doesn't matter how much effort you
put in if you're not really good you're
not going to win right well something
like this it can be just through pure
grind you can out you can beat other
people and at the time most of the stuff
that i was earning money through
required on seo the beauty of seo is you
can see rankings you can check rankings
and you know if i just do that a little
bit extra there i will get a little bit
of a bump up
you can see yourself eventually move
there'll be times when you get you go
down as well so there can be
disappointments but there's sometimes
when you get those you just think more
hours i can beat somebody who's they're
not gonna grind as much as i can i can
do more i'll work more and eventually
you could beat that we are going to take
a little quick break from the podcast to
introduce the sponsor of this podcast
which is curiosity stream if you haven't
heard by now curiosity streams is the
world's leading documentary streaming
subscription platform founded by john
hendricks who's the founder of the
discovery channel and on curiosity
stream they've got hundreds of really
high quality high budget documentaries
covering all sorts of things from
science and technology to history and
ancient civilizations to food and
medicine and meditation like all of the
stuff in between now the really cool
thing about curiosity stream is that
they support independent creators and so
there is this service called nebula
which you might have heard of it's an
independent streaming platform that's
run by me and a bunch of other creators
and on nebula we can put content like
videos and behind the scenes and long
form longer form stuff without worrying
about things like the youtube algorithm
and so for example in nebula i have a
bunch of exclusive content that you
won't find anywhere else we actually
have the original season zero of the
deep dive podcast which started off as
like remote zoom live streams during the
pandemic and that is only available on
nebula you won't find it anywhere else
so if you enjoy the sorts of
conversations we have on deep dive you
might like to see you know a whole year
before we started this podcast properly
once the pandemic stopped what sort of
conversations i was having with people
on zoom i've also got a series of videos
in nebula called workflow which is where
i deep dive into some of my favorite
productivity tools and on nebula you
also get early ad-free access to my
videos and videos from a bunch of other
creators that you might be familiar with
like thomas frank and tom scott and
legal eagle and lindsey ellis and the
really cool thing is that because
curiositystream loves supporting
independent creators we've got another
bundle deal which is that if you sign up
for an account on curiositystream you
actually get free access to nebula
bundled with that so if you head over to
curiositystream.com forward slash deep
dive then for less than 15 a year you
can get full access to curiosity
stream's incredible library of
documentaries and also free access to
all of the stuff on nebula bundled with
that so head over to curiositystream.com
forward slash deep dive to get the
bundle deal so thank you curiositystream
for sponsoring this episode are you
still going on going with the therapy
thing or was it like a few sessions
so yeah so it was an eight-week thing
and i kind of treated it like
an essay or an assignment or a game or
something throughout the whole therapy
session i would just be taking notes
like frantically on all the important
points and at the end i would make
myself an action plan yeah and then
during the week i would work on the
action plan and make sure that i was
actually doing the things that were
going to help me in some way shape or
form so let's say in therapy session one
we would identify x or y problem i would
think about how can i fix x y problem
work on it during the week and then
report back i fixed x i haven't haven't
quite fixed y let's work on that a
little bit more yeah that's very
something like productivity bro way of
dealing with therapy it is it is but i
can't imagine doing it any other way
yeah and i think i think half of therapy
is talking to someone else listening to
them
having them you know tell you things the
other half is you need to put in some
amount of work to try and change the
things that you're unhappy with or
or you know whatever it is that you need
to do
um so i think you need a little bit of
both for sure okay so we were talking
about like your pre and post therapy
self and you said one of the things
definitely is that you've taken taken
the foot of the gas a little bit shall
we say um that reminded me of a story
that derek sivers writes about in his
book i think it's in anything you want
where he talks about how he would always
go for a cycle every day
and it would take him 40 minutes to go
and he'd be sweating at the end of it
and he'd be like cool i need to need to
make my time it's 40 minutes then one
day he decided you know what i'm just
going to enjoy the cycle right it's like
oh cool like oh it's spanning the roses
on the way and picking up a little
pebble and like you know just like
actually enjoying the cycle ride and he
gets back he looks at the clock and it's
42 minutes and he's like damn was i
really huffing and puffing and wearing
myself out for the sake of two extra
minutes that seems a bit weird
that's a really excellent analogy of how
i feel pre and post therapy i'm still
achieving the same things i'm just
taking it a little bit more relaxed and
enjoying myself a little bit more and
really the amount of output that i'm
losing is minimal and that's the
realization that i've had which i didn't
have before i was under the assumption
that
you know i just have to continue working
up until the point that i go to sleep
because every night when i go to sleep i
look at my to-do list and there's 10
items on there and i'm like well i could
probably bang out two of these right now
before i go to bed or i can leave them
all tomorrow the obvious choice is to
bang two of these before i go to bed
let's get that done
nowadays so
post therapy right or during therapy for
the first time in my life i sat down in
bed and i watched a movie on netflix by
myself
up until that point yeah yeah right
which which sounds crazy right i mean
you know my girlfriend's been telling me
to do this forever my friends have been
telling me to do this forever and i
would always think to myself like why
would i do that when i could work on my
to-do list like it's not about being
unproductive it's just i wanted to do
the other things like i have this to-do
list of things that i genuinely enjoy
let me get some of them done yeah and so
now i just watch a movie before i go to
bed
and i do those two tasks in the morning
instead of the night before and i just
relax at the end of the day and unwind
like why do i need to be on this
constant hamster wheel of running
running running doing all this time
management stuff
i can just take a bit of a step back and
like you said it'll take me 42 minutes
instead of 40
and it's not the end of the world and
that's kind of
the change that i'm going through now
have you come across 4 000 weeks by
oliver berkman
you would enjoy it it's uh we've got it
here somewhere uh it's great it's like a
sort of 20 22 20 21 uh productivity book
in inverted commas but it's it's not
really about productivity it's it's it's
more it's more like a philosophical
approach to time management recognizing
that four thousand weeks is roughly the
amount of time we have on this earth
and uh once we accept the finitude of
existence and our own mortality we stop
uh trying to cram all these things and
juggle all these balls and we recognize
that there genuinely isn't enough time
for all the important things and
therefore something they're just gonna
have to be put in the bin for now
and uh it's a very liberating and
interesting read uh would recommend and
for anyone listening we have an
interview with oliver burkman which will
also be linked in the in the show notes
down below shameless plug very nice um
but yeah so i've i found myself having
similar realizations where
i
used to feel bad about like not replying
to people and now i don't feel bad about
replying to people unlike whatsapp or
emails and stuff and emails friends or
people on the internet watch your stuff
both to an extent like friends i still
feel a little bit bad because like it's
a friendship to maintain and i try not
to apply productivity bro lens to
friendships um but even friends to an
extent to be honest like i used to feel
guilty that oh i have these 80 unread
whatsapps and it's all people friends of
mine like even like yeah friends who
like i should be replying to and i know
i want to reply to them but like oh i
just can't bring myself to make the time
to to do this thing
and
now i guess what i've accepted is just
like yeah i'm just
that's okay like
maybe i will lose out on one or two
friendships because i was not
sufficiently good at replying to
whatsapp messages but actually that's
okay that's a sacrifice i'm willing to
make and the amount of extra stress it
adds to my life to feel the need to
maintain a a i don't know two hour
response time on it to whatsapps
does not justify uh
yeah it's just it's it's just not worth
it similarly with emails similarly with
what i found as well as random items on
my to-do list whereas i used to think of
my to-do list as i have to get all these
things done now i think of it as as long
as i just get the most important things
done each day it really does not matter
if all the other stuff does not get done
forever like indefinitely it doesn't
matter in the slightest it's actually
all good and unless like a tax bill
comes along which is too easy to put off
or something like that there are very
few things
that are genuinely necessary and
important on the to-do list and there's
certainly not going to be like 10 to 100
of them like i used to have
if i can just do my most important
taskies to each day and maybe and maybe
one or two other things
and i do that every day for a whole year
then i'll make so much more progress
than if i think of my to-do list as a
series of items that need checking off
definitely
i i think there's also a um
like thinking switch that you make where
you know my to-do list used to be
something that any time i'd strip one
thing off i would immediately think oh
okay what do i want to do next well i
want to start making merch i want to
start a patreon i want to upload a new
video i want to write a script for this
blah blah so there was always things to
add there was a never-ending
incoming stream of things that i could
potentially put on my to-do list yeah
and it's like you said what you need to
realize is like let me just focus on the
most important things that i want to do
right now once those are done i can
think about adding on a new project it
doesn't all have to get done before i go
to sleep at midnight or whatever
um
so
so yeah this this uh thinking shift in
time management from having to get
everything done as quickly as possible
as efficiently as possible
um
to just
taking a little bit less time but
enjoying it exponentially more
is something that's that i've been going
through and that i think is really
important i wish i had known it earlier
i wish i'd experienced it earlier um
and yeah it's kind of a change that i'm
trying to make now um yeah it reminds me
of something that i heard an emergency
medicine consultant say once on one of
my shifts which is that
don't worry about the list the list is
never ending the patients are going to
keep coming in and there's nothing you
can do about that so just embrace the
fact that there's nothing you can do
about the list and just focus on the
patient in front of you and try and make
that patient have a great time and then
focus on the next one in terms of
priority order in terms of triage and
then the next one and then the next one
and stop worrying about the list it's
all good if we breathe four hours who
cares like you know
we'll be all right we'll be all right we
got this yeah um it's that exact point
that there's a never-ending list of
patients and each one of them is going
to come with their sub sub list of tasks
that need to get done yeah um so yeah so
yeah just one at a time in triage
priority order one at a time and one day
trust trust in the process yeah so on
the go on the goal setting front um i i
also keep on trying to find the perfect
system for this like
um in in in terms of like like like
personal goals one of my theories
my philosophies shall we say
is that setting like i don't like it
when i set goals that are outside of my
control for example
when
i set the goal of i want a youtube video
that hits a certain view count right
compared to i want to make a video i'm
proud of when i think i want to write a
book that hits this under times my
seller list versus i want to write a
book i'm proud of and that's all fine
but that almost feels like it's oh well
i'll just do my best and not worry about
the outcome
which also which feels a little bit
unsatisfying
given
a bunch of research around the idea of
like effective goal setting and
challenging goal setting and the fact
that kind of high performers inverted
commas in most fields you know it's not
like michael phelps you know what i'll
just try my best and see what happens
right right yeah so yeah any any
thoughts around that tension between
i'll try my best versus i have this
specific outcome i'm aiming for which
may be somewhat outside of my control
it's interesting i mean i there's a sort
of sub distinction there between there's
the goal there's the things you can
control and things you can't control but
then there's
specificity or vagueness
in the things that you can
control and i i do think that like
things like doing your best and
being proud of things like they're
really important values in life but i
can see how they're not they're not
particularly helpful in this setting
because it's sort of completely
open-ended and so it's not very smart i
know right exactly either you
can either you will end up sort of not
doing what you could have done because
you say well that was my best so i don't
care like and you sort of you sort of
make it easy for yourself or you do what
i think i would do and have done in a
lot of my early adulthood which is like
be convinced that trying your best is
really important and then like torment
yourself constantly with like am i doing
my best is this my best am i can i you
know and those kind of open-ended things
seem unhelpful you on the other hand if
you say i mean this is where i feel like
quantity based goals can be really
helpful right if you say like i'm going
to put out this number of videos or this
number of i'm going to write
this many words uh on a by a certain
point firstly it's specific
secondly it's within your control and
then thirdly it's kind of
it's somewhat drained of the sort of the
quality of goals are sort of
they they they go wrong because they're
so sort of emotive there's something
kind of nice about a very very sort of
mechanistic
goal in that area i don't think it's the
whole piece of the puzzle because i do
think even though i wrote in my first
book about like
how positive visualization is largely
nonsense and all sorts of things i do
think there's clearly a role for kind of
envisioning the having a vision of where
you'd like things to be and using it to
determine what you do in the in the
present but that idea of just being
maybe this is like systems versus goals
that is this that old distinction but
it's like it's like the idea of saying
like
this many words
um
or you know just something really sort
of that sort of takes out all the
all the all the angst from it i think
that's gonna be really useful yeah well
one of the ways i'm thinking about it
because i'm i'm i was writing the
chapter about this in the book like this
week last week um
i intended to do this week as well but
then time goes away like like
um
is yeah like systems
i feel like all
all of this stuff converges on a few
central central themes and
we as productivity writers try to put
our own stamp on like a thing which
people have been doing for centuries not
millennia uh but that aside um
what i'm what i really like is is that
if i kind of break down my implicit
process of goal setting because it's
never been like explicit if i if i break
down what that looked like what it
looked like was step number one
setting a kind of destination goal that
is within my control like write a book
i'm proud of which is like this big
product big project
um maybe in my mind it's like it would
be really cool if it hit the best
outlets it would be really cool if i get
invited on conferences and if i i don't
know get on a podcast because
that would be sick but like those are
outside of my control so
let me just not think about those yeah
and just recognize that actually it's a
you know a preferred indifferent as as
the students as the stomachs might might
say yeah right um so the the destination
goal is within my control and then i'll
break that down into the kind of journey
goals which are is more the system stuff
therefore what i like tangibly need to
do is that every week or every day i
want to aim to write x thousand words or
x hundred words
and again that is within my control
and then kind of my step three of this
three-step process is
for that journey goal that like let's
say i want to write 500 words a day to
lower the bar of quality as much as
possible
yeah i want like i literally write my
to-do list write 500 crappy words for
crappy first draft of chapter two and i
find that putting the words crappy in
there twice
really makes it easier to be like okay
you know what this is actually it's
actually doable
let's do this great
it makes me think of two other things
like um dan harris meditation uh writer
and the podcaster um
talks about doing things specifically
meditation uh aiming to do them
daily-ish and having like having this
built-in built-in fuzziness like because
you know
whether you did something dailyish like
in a given week you you have a feel like
if you did it twice it wasn't dailyish
but it but it reduces this kind of like
oh if i break my streak it's all over
and i might as well spend the next three
weeks not doing anything um so i think
that's a that's an important part of
that and then something i've found
really helpful i don't know
if this is writing specific but like
might be just specific to writing but
it's also like not keeping going even if
you're on a roll so if you say like i'm
gonna write 500 words and you write them
and then things are going well like i
get another 500 out it's like actually
making yourself stop and walk away like
that kind of enforced low balling of
your of your aims for the day and like
that's really i think
for people like
i suspect you and certainly for me like
that's really hard to do yeah like when
the opportunity for a bit more
productivity arises and you don't take
it yes but there's this amazing old book
that i had to like buy as print on
demand because it's because it's so hard
to get called them how writers journey
to comfort and fluency by a psychologist
called robert boyce and it's like a
really in-depth study of academic
writers and what caused them to
be either productive or non-not
productive
i mentioned him in the book a couple of
times and like
one of his big findings was that the
writers who made writing into a
a moderately important part of their
lives were did lots more than the ones
who made it into a very important part
of their lives because then it becomes
this kind of intimidating thing and you
have sort of all sorts of angst about it
and you forget about it for weeks at a
time because you don't dare go back into
that scary thing and part of that is
like you figure out what is your short
daily session of writing
and he said like you know
for people sort of amateur writers that
might be 10 minutes a day even for
professional writers it probably should
never be more than like three or four
hours and when it's up you just you have
to stop and like go and do something
else because otherwise you're kind of
giving in to a
an impatient urge to be done with the
whole thing that will ultimately
backfire on you and cause you to sort of
dread uh yeah returning to the project
that ability to keep important things
relatively small in your life i think
it's like it's really i'm not saying i'm
any good at it yeah but it's it's really
interesting alrighty that brings us to
the end of season two of the podcast
huge thank you to anyone who has
listened downloaded subscribed any of
that kind of stuff and as a reminder we
do have the survey and also the link to
join the friendzone our completely free
community and we'd love for you to fill
in the survey so that we can help make
this podcast better anyway thank you
very much for watching or listening have
a great day and i will see you in the
next episode bye